hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and i've just
started a few months ago to create a
youtube channel
the reason i've done that is because i
want to show you everything i do at work
everything that can be useful for you if
you guys are new investors
or if even if you invest for a long time
and you want to see how protrader is
actually
working so in today's video i want to
make an analysis on gme
let's get into it
[Music]
so this is jamie chad for those who have
watched my
channel before you recognize my drawings
last time i did my video i was on the
four hours time frame because you know
as i always say this is the best time
frame to use
for long term or short term investments
so this is the time frame you're gonna
find the best reactions and i was
actually
telling you uh sorry this was amc we are
here on gme chart
right i was telling you guys that i was
seeing a triangle here
forming with a base horizontal basis at
160
and a downward sloping trend line that
was connecting the two highs that i had
here and here and at the close on friday
we actually closed just below so i told
you guys this
is not looking good i don't like that
but i was seeing that we have the 200
period moving average that was coming
here at 152 that we had the rebound here
and so it was unclear if this was a true
breakout or fake breakout
so let me just remind you something you
always need guys to have two scenarios i
always have two scenarios one
preferred scenario where definitely here
guys
i was bullish but i saw that on the
short term i had
some various signals that were starting
to form
so i was prepared for the downside
scenario to happen
and training is once again to always be
prepared to
everything to be able to adapt quickly
you need to plan your scenarios
before they actually happen because if
you don't have a plan for the
for the worst scenario then you're gonna
start
to improvise and to take decisions when
actually your emotions are guarding you
which is the worst thing that can happen
to a trader
is to be forced to take some decisions
when actually they are
panicking they are losing money and
trust me that those decisions are the
ones
that one day are gonna wipe you out are
gonna
make you lose everything so you don't
want this to happen so you need to have
a plan you need to be prepared
and you need to execute the plan exactly
as it was supposed to be so
here i'm going to show you what would
have been my plan once again guys i
don't trade
u.s stocks i'm a pro trader i have a
contract i'm not allowed as part of my
contract
to actually take positions on any
u.s shares and here
what i would have done i told you
careful this triangle
is starting to break out on the damn
side but we need to wait
um until the first four hours on
training
of training on monday before actually
saying this is broken and confirmed then
we know it's broken and confirmed we
know we get it we're going lower
i mean we never know for sure but the
preferred scenario changes
so the plan is exit the position
so look at the chart
first four hours here the scandal
doesn't count because this is a closing
candle it's
it's like a 15 minute scandal so the
four the last four hours of training on
friday we're here
and here we have the first four hours of
training on monday
right so basically it confirmed it went
it opened and one 158 it went to
116 and then close just here
so you have your breakout confirmation
so then you know that your support just
became resistance
and that probably we're gonna get there
before getting rejected and this is
where
you place selling orders so i i mean you
know i'm on the
short time trading on the day trading
perspective
if you guys are long-term investors you
don't need to do all the stuff you just
need to know where you're going to
reload
you cannot reload and just buy any dip
this is not
i mean the best thing to do you need to
have some levels in mind
where you know you're gonna buy and you
need to use the short term
if you have time for this you need to
use the short term price action
to actually set up your buying trades
when the market is showing some
short-term reversal signs i'm gonna get
to it right now
but first what i would have done here
i would have actually put ascending
order at exactly here guys you know
my uh triangle basis triangle so it's
like 160
you know it's the lowest level we have
here one thing's 163.2
and what is the scandal where is the
scandal going the highest level was
163.7
so i have zero five points uh buffer
where i actually would have been
executed not at the best level of this
day but almost you see so this is how
you use your support levels because they
actually become
resistance then you have exited your
position
all right so you feel comfortable you
can take
good decision you don't panic your
emotions are not
making you do any stupid decision and
now what you are looking for is a level
to reload
so once again yes that's why technical
analysis is a survival kit that's why
it's what you all need to do i heard
some of you telling me yeah but gamestop
is a manipulated stock
maybe maybe i mean hedge funds are
attacking many stocks you know but it
has always been like this
but the psychological mechanisms that
are you know in place
that are at stake in finance are
actually here
as well even if the stock gets hammered
for some hedge fund reason uh you know
they decided to attack the stock
i mean people are going to react exactly
the same way if it was a bad news you
know it's just the price gets hammered
and they need to to buy it at a good
level
and then the bullish momentum comes back
and everybody starts to see good news
everywhere even if they are not
and i'm gonna come to this very soon so
i finished the story you sold everything
here
if you follow your plan once again guys
always two scenarios you cannot have
only one scenario you need to be
prepared
and to know what you're gonna do if what
you're going to do is nothing
it's fine you can just tell me i don't
have plan b
my plan a is we go to the moon and i'm
going to keep my shares until my plane a
actually happened fair enough it's a
plan a
that's is good and your plan b is if
it goes lower i don't do anything all
right that's fine too
your plan b could be as well i reload
then you really need to
to think about where you're gonna buy
the dip
you you need to prepare this in advance
you cannot buy the jeep just you wake up
and oh gamestop is actually showing
lower i'm gonna buy this deep
you know it's not working like this if
you do that you you're gonna get wiped
out
trust me so here you're gonna hourly
time frame
and you're looking for some deep to buy
when i do my analysis i don't have any
support level before 115
so of course i have a buying order at
115
if i want to buy the dip but in this
situation we didn't go that low
so i'm gonna give you a technique that
works very well guys i'm using this
every day
every day i'm doing this kind of stuff
and it's working let's say 80 of the
time
so i'm just gonna give you a technique
that here you know is
working perfectly you connect due to
recent highs here and here
in the wave you are considering so you
cannot for example take one high
in one wave and another high in another
wave for example you cannot do that
here you can see clearly that's why i do
my idiot wave counting i have one wave
here
one wave here so abc one two three four
five
let me add this one
so one two three all right
you cannot for example do a trend line
between this high
and and this one okay
between here the maximum here and the
maximum here this trend line
is useless you can see this one that i
did here i'm gonna put in red
this trendline is not a good trend line
because it's connecting
two highs from two different waves no
not working
never do this that's why you need to
define your waves properly
here when we are going down like this
it's quite easy you can you know you
don't need to do technical analysis for
a long time to actually
see that you have one wave
just going lower it's like my c wave
that is here
you know it's just one way down so then
you connect
this and this and it gives you
so you can do it like you know here
here whatever and you always have
all the signals coming together you have
here the consolidation
just below the breakout level and the
short time it works
for the first time frame for the daily
time frame it works for every
time frame but what is good about the
hourly time frame guys is that
you know things go quickly you you you
don't need to be
that patient if you do this on a daily
timeframe you need to wait like six
seven days
here you only need to wait like six
seven hours so it's
less than i mean it's like a trading day
and here
once you have your breakout once again a
breakout two consecutive candles in the
time frame you're watching
training above your level so one two
then you buy oh sorry so you would have
bought
here guys at 142. 142 is the level you
would have bought
if you follow this method so that's it
for me guys you know i just wanted to
show you in this video
how a pro trader is actually making his
trades i mean this is exactly what i
would have done
and i never put myself in a situation
where i lose control i never put myself
in a situation
where um i don't i don't know what to do
i always have a plan
at work i mean you know i do this every
day at work i always have a plan
i don't hope for something to happen of
course
you know i have my preferred scenario of
course i hope my preference tonight
would happen
but i don't feel bad if it doesn't
happen
i know what to do of course i'm gonna
take a small loss
or maybe i'm going to take a big loss
because for example here
what would have happened if we don't go
to my level
then i wouldn't have sold and then i
would have taken this
big move down you know in my face
so then i would have probably stopped it
somewhere here
you know because in the way i work you
cannot hold the position if
your plan is not good so even if here we
would have gone close to my level and i
wouldn't have get
sold i would have exited the position
slowly slowly slowly
and whatever the level you know just you
need to exit
and then i would have reloaded here the
way i told you so any
whatever happens guys there's always a
plan there's always
uh something good to do and you need to
be prepared
for this so yes that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show see you guys